great is speaking up about what topics
and why what are they afraid of and it
turns out everyone's afraid of the
students more than the faculty they're
afraid to talk about race what about the
administrators everyone's afraid of the
students they're afraid of the students
so I don't have we've not suited them
I've only surveyed students I don't okay
okay but from what we hear people are
afraid of of the students was hauling in
its own manner like was that real your
leaders where that's for sure they let
those kids come into the classroom the
actual classroom and disrupt a class on
an ongoing basis I mean yes and I
couldn't understand that exactly I mean
my response to that would be first I
would tell them to leave second I would
call campus security third if something
wasn't done about it I just wouldn't
teach the class so I don't understand
like it seems to me that it's also up to
individual professors to draw a line
which is that if you're being
intimidated by students why do you why
do you show up and teach the class I
don't understand that yeah so um again
people are afraid to stand up if it
means that people will call you a racist
cabott got it I mean it's what's weird
in that situation though it scary to
you're also authority to go to your
class you know and there's a much more
proximal threat there that's what I mean
that's what I'm most alarmed by is the
rise of intimidation intimidation is now
a factor in many aspects of academic
life and that's just terrible that's
completely incompatible with what we do
and who we are
well it's especially it's especially
appalling given that whatever happens in
the university campuses you know we're
like one of the questions I faced in
Canada is well why should we care about
what's happening yeah and the in the Ivy
tile if you're gonna hire these people
next year you are well yeah well they're
it's the heart like what's happening in
the campus is going to happen in society
in five years it's already that goes
it's already